[Music]
well I think there are only two really
big questions for science still to
answer lots of little ones of course but
one of them is the nature of
consciousness and the nature of
understanding and car science can
illuminate aesthetics and the other one
is they know where it all comes from and
how it came about so how did absolutely
nothing roll over into being what
appears to be something and science is
moving towards being able to answer that
kind of question maybe years off but
nevertheless that's its direction of
travel I mean science is over the past
well a century really has been moving
back in time looking at the the current
universe in ever more detail and going
back really very close to the moment of
Inception and it'd be rather
disheartening to think that's we're
going to be stopped and not be able to
get back right to the instant of
Inception and indeed even to think
beyond that and to say well how is it
that it came about and scientists are
optimists and they should always think
that really big questions will be
resolved if they spend enough time and
effort I'm afraid money in in tackling
those questions so I think that you know
science has got back to within reliably
in this universe true within nanoseconds
plausibly - - within fractions
nanoseconds and I'd hate to think that
there was a barrier that the prevented
us getting back to year dot
it's not time travel in in the science
fiction sense it's really in looking
back in time and looking back in time
observational II because when we looking
to the into the universe through our
telescopes where we're looking back in
time and since effectively because of
the finite speed of light so were
observational we're looking further and
further back to nearly 14 billion years
ago when the universe began but also
theoretically that we can construct
theories about the evolution of the
universe and trace those theories back
in time
[Music]
equipment that is basically like a very
very very advanced telescope no it means
we have equipment like very ordinary
telescopes I mean of course that they
the more sensitive they are though the
more distant the objects that you can
observe sensibly and the more distant
then the longer the light has taken to
reach us and therefore the further back
in time it began its journey towards us
so that's simply our time we can do time
travel in that sense simply by looking
at their existent objects and they the
more sensitive the telescope and
telescopes are getting more sensitive by
the minute as it were the further back
in time we can go
and the theory about it where do you
stand in what do you think is correct
about the current theories we have about
the origins of the universe well
currently we have new theories about the
actual origin of the universe be
wonderful if we had I mean we've got a
number of speculations and I've
speculated as well how nothing how
absolutely nothing can roll over into
appearing to be something which then 14
billion years later evolves into into us
but we've got very substantial theories
about the history of the universe as we
know it so we can be pretty confident
about the last although all except the
last use the peeved the first few
seconds of the universe
what have been I've not changed my mind
I've developed thoughts and the book
that I've recently written is about one
aspect of the origin of the universe
which is the origin within it of the
laws of nature how they might come into
existence and contrary to more
complicated theories I think that there
may arise from a mixture of indolence
anarchy and ignorance and I think there
was a very there's a three very powerful
principles as to the the deeper question
about why absolutely nothing
rolled over into being something I've
thought about that and written about
that but it's pure speculation but what
I wanted to do is not to present my own
theory but to show that it was not
inconceivable that one could discuss
apparently outrageous events in
scientific terms the language of science
would not fail even before the universe
came into existence and that was a
difficult thing to do but I I tried to
do it it was certainly not any pretense
of being a theory of the origin of the
universe although I spent suspect
privately that it might be right
the origins of the laws of nature yes
smoke I I think that when absolutely
nothing rolled over into being
apparently something they are apparently
something inherited they the uniformity
of the absolute nothing from which was
its parent never mind how the rolling
over happened that's another question
but having inherited the uniformity of
absolutely nothing there are
consequences of that and there's a very
deep theorem proposed by any nutter a
German mathematician in the early 20th
century which shows that whenever you
have uniformity of some kind then you
have a conservation law and say one of
the great laws of nature is the
conservation of energy and theorem shows
that that is a consequence of the
uniformity of time so if you can show
that when the universe came into
existence it inherited the uniformity of
nothing and time on a cosmic scale was
uniform than you've immediately are
cutting accounted for the uniform and
for the conservation of energy so that
was one wing of my argument
yes well then if some indolence is too
vigorous for you then you resort to
anarchy I think and you will know any
kind of behavior to happen and I think
you can show in certain aspects you can
show that if you allow every conceivable
mode of behavior then some of it is self
annihilating and you're left with very
simple behavior which does survive so
Anarchy leads to the two laws of nature
like the propagation of light and
because particles have a wave nature it
needs also to the propagation of
particles and therefore it leads to
quantum mechanics and because quantum
mechanics leads to classical mechanics
it leads through whole collection of the
laws of nature
well it's I think there are two steps
one is you know where do the laws come
from and then what are the consequences
and so I don't bother about the
consequences I leave that to scientists
to work out you know I'm interested but
it's not my prime concern I mean the
real concern is what are the laws and
where do those come from other people
can then trouble themselves by working
out the consequences for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you